I would say you know you can't go long
but yes like I have to pull it off there
so Tom I read that you audition seven
times or over 70/7 audition takes 80
harms 80 okay one of those teams consist
of just back to like hey welcome back to
it I should be far away on silent
watch what I can do it was just me
showing off really I love that Omni is
sexy in this film I think she's really
sexy and as it's kind of like glamour to
her did you have any say in her hair and
makeup or her wardrobe at all yes I knew
it I do thank you for noticing a lot of
wigs and a lot of clothes and came up
with a look that also was also had to be
very clean like clean lines that would
also match with like a comic book
character in its own way so even if
those the real life person have almost
like an iconic uniform and I think it
was film to me so cool clearly
celebrates diversity it's the most
diverse vitamin I didn't even ever seen
yeah
how important is that versus a feature
this franchise it's so important I think
John did such a great thing by you know
breaking the stereotype in casting for
whom he thought was best for the role
rather than what they look like in the
comics was 16 things it was a beautiful
step in the right direction it's an
accurate representation of what he
relied in grace to keep seeing I think
John and Marvel including women we were
all cast base and we're the right person
for this character as opposed to like oh
we want a black girl if Liz or you know
like all of these boxes like we're not
here to check boxes here because like
we're the accurate people's appreciate
them it really has made this film
grounded it really feels like a real New
York high school because they are so
diverse you know movies like this it's
continuing to break down that wall and I
think that's what we're supposed to do
and then die I think that for you so
many folks have high hopes for your film
careers your first big film your
professor yeah I want to ask you would
you ever play a superhero intuitive Oh
to me I don't know what it would be well
I would be down for whatever
they're like a strong female powerful
care
you